there's gonna be a lot more releasing
than music Katy Perry's pregnant I had
to reveal it at some point
it's gettin any obvious yep
on Wednesday Katy revealed she's
expecting her first child with her
fiance Orlando Bloom in a totally casual
no big deal kind of way
just kidding it was freaking epic watch
it all the way to the end in' and
there's a little reveal katie dropped
the music video for her new song never
worn white and fully showed off her
sweet little baby bump at the end
fans first suspected the baby news when
Katie shared this teaser for the video
earlier in the day she also hinted
something major was coming on Twitter
writing let's just say it's gonna be a
jam-packed summer I am excited I am
excited we're excited and happy and it's
probably the longest secret I've ever
had to keep and I like to tell you guys
everything but I knew I would tell you
in the best way which is through a piece
of music after the music video premiered
at Katie hit up insta live to do a
little Q&A there's a lot that will be
happening this summer not only will I be
giving birth literally but also
figuratively
she basically snacked on dried mango the
whole time I know the chomping is
disgusting I've turned into a real mouth
breather and a real like I'm sorry you
carry and call me
and speaking of food the singer dished
on her pregnancy cravings I like
literally never cared for spice and now
I have to carry Tabasco sauce in my
purse like that woman foods that grossed
me out now our beef okay but back to the
music I hope you like never worn white I
wrote it a long time ago and I'm sure
you can tell who it's about
katie has been engaged to Orlando Bloom
since last February and she said that
the lyrics to her new song are literally
true she explained that she wore a dove
gray dress not a white dress when she
married her first husband Russell Brand
in 2010 it's gonna be my first time
wearing white gotta love that
technicality
Orlando has a nine-year-old son Flynn
who me
with his ex-wife Miranda Kerr as for
Katie being a mom was always something
she wanted just check out what she told
et in 2013 do you think you never have
kids down the road of course I think
when the time is right I will probably
make my biggest project
my biggest collaboration bus for and
that's when I will focus a lot more of
my time over to being a good mother and
giving as much attention as children
need well she's in it now and something
tells me she'll be a great mama this is
a journey it's a while I always knew I
was like you know like a mother like a
mother of the house a mother to the kids
but now I'm gonna be a mother and miss
kitty purry well she's just happy the
cats out of the bag bad joke I know I'm
sorry she tweeted quote OMG so glad I
don't have to suck it in anymore or
carry around a big purse lol but my
favorite part of this whole insta live
well just watch it for yourself I'm done
with this I'm taking out some of my hair
she straight up just took out her weave
look that ish is heavy AF and if that's
not relatable I don't know what is yeah
okay it's done Katie we love you and we
are so happy for you and that's sweet a
little bundle of joy of course you can
count on ET to bring you all the latest
on Katie and Orlando so keep it locked
or right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens I'll see you soon
[Music]